50 years ago the United States Congress
established the Strategic petroleum
reserve and at the time the idea was to
ensure that America would have a stable
supply of energy in the event of a
natural disaster or more likely in the
case of a war in the Middle East the
reserve was like a fire extinguisher in
a building that read break CL glass in
case of emergency it was a last resort
to be used only if somehow the us could
neither generate its own energy nor find
oil for reasonable prices overseas when
the Biden Administration took control
the federal government a few years ago
all of that changed and for one thing
the bid Administration shut down
existing drilling sites and prevented
new oil leases from being signed and
then to add insult injury Joe Biden's
handlers used the Strategic Reserve to
temporarily lower the price of gas in
the weeks before the midterm elections
nothing like that had ever happened in
the history of this country it was a
really big deal that not a lot of people
paid attention to but the bid
Administration insisted that you know
this was necessary because War had
broken out Ukraine and as a result we
needed to ban Russian oil imports they
told us again and again that this was a
once in a-lifetime situation they said
it was it was precisely the kind of
emergency that justified the use of the
Strategic Reserve well less than two
years later it's clear to everyone that
the Biden Administration was either
lying or totally incompetent or probably
both that's because once again we're
confronted with yet another war that no
one saw coming supposedly this time it's
a war in the middle exactly the kind of
conflict that Congress established the
the Strategic Reserve to deal with in
the first place so what's the plan what
do we do now that we've tapped our uh
emergency oil reserves to the point that
they're at the lowest level in four
decades probably won't surprise you to
hear that nobody in the bid
Administration has an answer to that
question no one on the right does either
actually instead both political parties
are now calling for US military
intervention in the Middle East that
would deplete our oil supply even
further when I say military intervention
I mean that Republicans are calling for
allout war with a nuclear power so
here's lindsy Graham the other day
explaining that we need to start bombing
Iran's oil refineries watch well for
every Israeli or American hostage
executed uh by Hamas we should uh take
down an Iranian oil refinery the only
way you're going to keep this war from
escalating is to hold Iran accountable
how much more death and destruction do
we have to take from the Iranian regime
I am confident this was planned and
funded by the Iranians Hamas is a bunch
of animals uh who deserve to be treated
like animals so if I was Israel I would
go in on the ground there is no truce to
be had here I would dismantle Hamas this
is the best opportunity Israel has to
destroy Hamas take it to the Iranians if
you harm one American in Syria by using
your Iranian militia against us in Syria
if you escalate the war by urging
Hezbollah to attack Israel in the north
if Hamas kills one American and Israeli
hostage we're going to blow up your oil
refineries and put you out of business
it is now time to take the war to the
iola's
backyard yes let's uh let's keep this
from escalating by bombing Iran's oil
refineries that you know that that's how
you deescalate a situation now what
would happen if the Pentagon did exactly
what Lindsey Graham said and started
bombing Iran would the price of oil
instantly increase by
500% would Iran retaliate using the
nuclear weapons that they probably have
by now who knows what we do know is that
the end result for America would almost
certainly be bad I mean it's hard to
imagine any scenario where any average
American's life is improved by blowing
up Iran's oil
refineries but Lindsey grah doesn't care
he doesn't care about Americans at all
that's the truth he's an unhinged
Reckless neocon who should have been run
out of political office years ago yet
like so many other neocons in both the
Republican and Democrat parties he
remains in place constantly hatching new
schemes to make uh you know to to hurt
this country and its people schemes that
by the way aren't going to affect him at
all so here's the point where it becomes
necessary to take uh 10 steps back and
assess the situation from a distance
pretend you're say the leader of the
Communist Party of China and you've been
looking for an opportunity to expand
your borders for a very long time with a
particular eye towards Hong Kong and
Taiwan and then you see this the
government of the United States
supposedly the world's preeminent
superpower is shutting down its own
domestic energy production at the same
time it's destroying its own domestic
supply of
petroleum put two and two together and
the message from the bid Administration
is pretty clear that message is this our
leaders have no idea what they're doing
and as if to emphasize that point the
bid Administration has stumbled over
itself repeatedly since the invasion of
Israel began over the weekend the state
department sent not one but two tweets
out telling Israel to sign a ceasefire
without retaliating in any way for the
attack on on their Homeland one of those
tweets was from Tony blinken's account
and both of those tweets were deleted
within 24 hours which which really
inspires confidence you know then on
Monday to add insult injury Joe Biden's
account tweeted something about how he's
um going to ban junk fees charged by
Airlines and concert venues that's what
he's thinking about right now he's
thinking about junk
fees now this is the laziest possible
form of voter engagement and it's one
that Joe Biden's handlers keep coming
back to vote for us and Ticket Master
will be more upfront with its
fees what an inspiring platform and by
the way since we're on the subject
briefly uh you know uh we all pay a
significant amount of junk fees every
day courtesy of the IRS so Biden wants
to wants Airlines to stop buking us of
every last scent and by the way I want
them to stop stop that too except that
the government his own government is
doing the same thing and to a much
greater
extent so perhaps you should take the
plank out of the government's own eye
before worrying about the speck in
Ticket Master now again our adversaries
in China and elsewhere they can see all
this they can see a nation that's
completely unprepared for a massive
International crisis up to and including
the outbreak of World War III
potentially the signs are everywhere
there's really no way that anyone could
deny it at this point we are an
unserious Nation led by the most
unserious ious people imaginable one of
those unserious people happens to lead
the department of interior and here she
was just days before the Hamas
terrorists invaded Israel uh here's what
she was thinking about
[Music]
watch Patty I am so excited to be here
with you at Stonewall National Monument
with the beautiful Flags behind us tell
me in your own words why places like
this like Stonewall are so important to
telling America's
story that's a great question I think
it's because queer rights are more under
attack than ever and I think if we don't
acknowledge the past we're bound to
repeat it so at a place like Stonewall
this beautiful place it's a place where
so much discrimination and hatred
occurred against the queer Community but
it's also a place where resistance and
queer joy and queer Liberation
happened so that is the secretary of the
Department of the interior of the United
States she oversees all federal lands
and natural resources in this country
including regulations concerning oil and
gas leasing uh and uh but she's that's
what she's doing right now she can't be
bothered with the prospect of war in the
Middle East now to be fair the
department of interior is not alone in
that respect plenty of other US
government agencies and departments have
been wasting their time with frivolous
virtue signaling they don't care about
keeping you safe or preparing for World
War I or better yet working to actually
avoid World War III which would really
be
the best that would be what I would
prefer instead they're fixated on
diversity and equity and inclusion just
a few days ago the Wall Street Journal
and this is some uh great timing on this
they ran a truly extraordinary piece
explaining how the US military is
overrun with so-called skinny fat
recruits according to the pieace quote
one problem the Army faces these days is
a high number of skinny fat recruits
these people don't look out of shape but
indeed are are because of sedentary
Lifestyles that have left them with low
muscle mass and frail B bones and
connective tissue at Fort Moore in uh in
Georgia new soldiers are given calcium
supplements to counter a recent uptick
and broken feet and bones in the legs
according to several senior soldiers in
charge of training well nothing wrong
with that nothing to worry about we just
have Army recruits that need calcium
supplements so that their bones don't
fracture when they're going for a jog or
something this is the state of the US
Military and the reason why we're in
this state is well there's a lot of
reasons for one of them is that we're
looking at the situation after years of
purges in which so-called vaccine
Skeptics were removed from the service
you know and you've got a bunch of
overweight slobs who are quote skinny
fats and these are the people standing
between you and the potential foreign
Invasion
Force I mean how many skinny fat
soldiers do you think they have in I
don't know the Chinese Army
exactly does anybody with a brain think
the number is higher than
zero now if we lived in a serious
country we'd expel all these skinny fat
troops from our military we'd insist on
some standards and we'd do it fast and
we would also be recruiting people
because we're looking for you know tough
men who want to kill the enemy and
protect the country like that's the kind
of recruiting we'd be doing instead for
for a very long time the recruitment you
know they've putting out as we've played
on the show they've putting out
recruitment ads that look like Disney
movies going either way to recruit women
and you know non-b AR and
transgenders because we don't live in a
serious country so instead our
government is preoccupied with uh with
this sort of thing and with other things
too like social media feuds for example
the other day the White House went after
the very popular account Libs of Tik Tok
uh why is that well because Libs of Tik
Tok did what Libs of Tik Tok always does
she revealed what leftists particularly
leftists and power are doing she didn't
distort anything she didn't lie she just
held up a mirror and in this particular
case Liv of Tik Tok held a mirror up to
Tyler Cherry he's a Communications
official at the department of interior
which is the same agency that
interviewed the fetishist at Stonewall
which we just showed you so a lot of
interesting things happening over at the
department of interior but L Tik Tok
posted Tyler Cherry's Photo along with
his many deranged social media posts in
which he rants about rushia Gades and
Compares police officers to slave
patrols so here's what uh he looks like
and here's the picture now of course
it's usually not polite to mock
somebody's physical appearance but at
some point you're allowed to look at
somebody and form some common sense
conclusions you know you can tell what
corrupt ideology they subscribe to just
by looking at them this is certainly one
of those cases the fact that this person
moonlights as an activist on social
media is just more evidence that were
led by deeply unserious people now you
may recall that a bunch of uh a bunch of
us right-wing bigots we jumped to very
similar conclusions about the energy
official Sam Brittain uh last year and
when we did we were condemned as
homophobes and in that case all we did
was look at the guy and how he dressed
and we said something's not right here I
don't I don't think this person should
be working in government and we were
told oh open your mind be tolerant few
months later Britain was fired and under
arrest for stealing women's luggage from
the
airport so you can indeed judge a book
by its cover it turns
out
now admittedly if you're approaching
this from a distance all of this might
seem like a social media drama it might
seem inse consequential but but but it's
not this is what your government is
spending its time doing as a second
major war erupts under their watch in
just two years they're worried about
Libs of tick tock they're concerned with
backing up their fetishist in the
department of the
Interior what this means is that if
World War III does break out at some
point in the near future God
forbid which unfortunately seems
increasingly likely considering that we
are led by a parade of morally corrupt
circus
clowns well that happens then we are
unprepared to put it mildly we aren't
simply incapable of handling the next
Global crisis whether it's an invasion
of Taiwan or something even worse our
leaders can't even run their own Twitter
accounts in a responsible and coherent
fashion this is not just
embarrassing the problem is that for the
enemies of this country it's an
opportunity and let's pray they don't
take advantage of it if You' like to see
what else I have to say you can access
my full show by going to dailywire.com
or by going to the Matt wall Show
Twitter page age hope to see you there
God speed